لقد سمعنا جميعًا عن الفئران في غطاء محرك السيارة ولكن
الفئران على غطاء محرك السيارة ظهرت في
نهاية رحلة استغرقت ثلاث ساعات بالسيارة
من بروكلين، أحضرت فأرًا معي إلى
حفل زفاف في شمال نيويورك،
الشيء الوحيد الذي يمكنك فعله هو  مجرد نوع من الاستمرار في
القيادة، أعني أن التعليقات على
وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي تشبه وضع مساحات الزجاج الأمامي،
لكن كيفن كوبيه كان على بعد دقائق
من وجهته، لذا استمر في
الذهاب إلى حيث "لقد كان هناك في أي
لحظة بدا وكأنه سيذهب
إليها".  انفجر أو أي شيء لا وهو
على الزجاج الأمامي ولا توجد قبضة هناك
أو أي شيء من هذا القبيل، لذلك دهشت منه
عندما وصل كيفن إلى حفل الزفاف، ألهم
الضيف غير المدعو بالصراخ
لا أعرف إلى أين،
نعم، لا أعرف إلى أين  لقد حدث ذلك،
لا تأكل أسلاكي وبالتأكيد لا
تقود السيارة
بعيدًا، قام الباحثون في جامعة
ريتشموند بتعليم 17 فأرًا قيادة
سيارات كهربائية صغيرة قبل بضع سنوات باستخدام حلقات ذهابًا وإيابًا
كحوافز، حيث قاموا بتوجيهها من خلال
وضع أقدامهم على ثلاثة أفقية
الأسلاك النحاسية التي جعلت السيارة تتحرك يمينًا ويسارًا
أو بشكل مستقيم، كانت لديهم بعض
الاصطدامات المباشرة ولكن في النهاية تمكنوا من
صنع طبق
الحلوى كما لو كانوا
متجهين إلى
مطعم ماكدونالدز عندما انتهت احتفالات الزفاف
بعد يومين كيفن  لم يتم العثور على أي أسلاك
تمضغ أي شخص في المنزل ولا توجد علامة على وجود فأر،
تأكد من أنه يمكنك شراء قارض مزيف لتزيين
سيارتك ولكن سيارة كيفن بي إم دبليو كان لديها
فأر حي يتنفس لتزيين غطاء
محرك السيارة.